Oh
[Music]
good evening as reigning world champions
and with that Eastern Conference
champions we welcome the representatives
from each of the Eastern playoff houses
to the annual feast of the east to kick
off this year's playoffs so please
beef oh my god look at the vigor so many
wings how parents is happy another in
case it was pretty pretty we took the
horse
[Music]
hey what are you staring at that pot of
gold behind me there's some rock in my
teeth no I'm just looking at the
second-best team of the big balls for
such a small man yeah yeah I've heard it
all before it's too short
you can't play defense well he isn't
even the best Isiah Thomas
but somehow distorts been scoring 30
points the game hitting cooked shots and
how skeltox owns the number one seed
when this tournaments over you're all
gonna look up at me and you'll know
there's a new king in the east this
again didn't we do this last year we've
got chemistry and the debate to take you
down don't sleep on a TV for their King
for the North will soon Rory we are the
new kings of the eat this again didn't
we do this last year 60 wins countin he
puts us in the one seed and our house
goes 12 men deep we are the Spurs of the
East
tell em Korver bird man bomb this year
there will be a new king of the east
we're doing this again
you're on your last leg LeBron
there will be a new king in the east and
this time I mean it
people you literally did this last year
the era of poor George Roy Heather and
house faces begins now
verticality there will be a new king in
the East we're doing as they say you're
sitting can't be big but we got the
original big way and I say anything is
possible
kg was wrong it's not true
nothing is possible there's no point in
trying the Bronwen see every year we
should all be thanking the playoffs are
traveling they're gonna beat us off if
the trap without a gravity
okay
[Music]
you